he thought his hair would grow back
but i guess it hasn't so please welcome
colonel alfredo to the stage
good afternoon everyone i'm colonel
alfredo corbett the deputy director of
cyberspace and information dominance for
headquarters air combat command
um hopefully you enjoyed that fun fact
um that was
set up of me uh yeah i expected my hair
to grow back after i shaved it but i
think it looks good now
i'm glad to be here and thank you for
allowing me to share with you
air combat commands data enterprise
strategy
we've come a long way in a short period
of time but still have a ways to go
and with that i'll begin the
presentation so this afternoon i'd like
to talk to you about some of the actions
that we are taking
at air combat command or acc for short
to better position us for information
dominance
we have undertaken a comprehensive
assessment of our entire data workforce
our data infrastructure and our culture
in an effort to better position us for
the future of warfare
this means improving data management
capabilities enhancing data access
and sharing especially with our mission
partners and delivering advanced
analytics
including through artificial
intelligence we're currently putting
final touches on our data operation plan
to define how we will implement the task
to align and comply
with the department of the air force
department of defense guidance and
especially as it's contained in the dod
strategy
and the air force implementation plan on
the right-hand side of this slide
is a memorandum from the deputy
commander of air combat command
lieutenant general christopher wegeman
he signed this document earlier this
year
and issuing his guiding principle for us
in developing a plan that implements the
department of defense
data strategy general wigan's vision is
four-fold
first it establishes an integrated data
governance capability at all levels
then it creates a modern data reference
architecture that aligns with dod and
air force standards
and then also integrates and delivers
improved data management and governance
practices by integrating dod
and air force data standards with an
emphasis on data access
exploitation and sharing and lastly it
establishes a modern acc enterprise data
platform
that brings together data data
management and discovery and analytics
tools
we'll talk more about some of these
themes as we go through today's briefing
the bottom left-hand graphic is the
department of the air force
and it outlines the vision of the air
force chief data officer miss eileen
badrin
our data must be vault visible
accessible
understandable linked and trustworthy in
developing acc's roadmap to our data
centric future
we've relied on acc us air force
and dod principles and guidance that
same guidance
has guided our approach as i mentioned
on the previous slide
we focused on conducting a robust and
holistic assessment of our current data
strategy
people processes and metrics we
interviewed 30 executives across
acc and collected inputs from almost 700
airmen across the organization
our findings and the resulting reports
span eight different capability areas
and we'll start at the top of the
graphic and work our way around
clockwise
data governance is the foundation of
effective data management
enabling data to be integrated into an
enterprise-wide
data management solution by codifying
and enforcing data and technology
standards
developing a data-centric workforce and
integrating data efforts across
functional teams so if data governance
is the foundation of our data management
success
data architecture is the foundation of
the technology
that enables data effectiveness an
effective enterprise
data architecture when it exists
optimizes the ingest
storage processing integration usage
access delivery and exploitation of data
in the air force it is paramount that
our data architecture
is able to operate at what we call the
speed of war
delivering the right data at the right
time to the right fight warfighter
a process that in combat operations can
be fractions of a second
metadata management creates a
standardized framework for generating
controlling classifying and managing our
data assets
it's the data about data effective meta
data management is crucial to enabling
data access whether it be through data
discovery
data classification at the attribute
level rather than the system or network
level
and master data management ensures that
there is a single and
authoritative version of the truth and
requires that common entities are
represented
using a standard consolidated framework
now data quality preserves the value of
information assets by safeguarding it
from corruption and
ensuring accuracy accuracy when we talk
about information life cycle management
we are talking about ensuring that
collection preservation
and disposition of data not only conform
with federal laws and regulations
but also enhances rather than hinders
operational successes
and information privacy and security
focuses on security and access policies
and tools that permit authorized access
and prohibit
unauthorized access this capability area
is especially important
in a military context where classified
operations and communications are common
and where personally identified
information is everywhere
finally enterprise analytics focuses on
instituting reporting processes that are
baked into mission processes
but also on developing common tools to
analyze data
now on this slide depicts the approach
as we have tackled it at acc
taking into account the eight capability
areas that we just discussed on the
previous slide
so looking at the slide from left to
right we established a clear vision that
is part of the deputy commander's
guiding principles
that we mentioned on the first slide
then we conducted on
an assessment of our organization's
maturity and developed a plan to set a
data management office
that can implement these changes over
the next five years
we also developed a target reference
architecture to be implemented by our
nascent data management office the
graphic at the bottom
highlights what the architecture looks
like and i'll discuss
more in a moment in order to define and
prioritize the organization's goals and
objectives
we develop four mission-focused use
cases
that identified a real ongoing
operational problem for the acc
warfighter
across aviation cyber and other enabling
communities
and highlighted methods that enterprise
data management can solve
and lastly we put pen to paper and wrote
a data operating plan
that assesses our current state
identifies our target
describes the gaps between the two and
builds a roadmap to get there
so what have we found out so before i
talk through some of our findings on the
left
let's take a brief detour to talk
through the concept of multi-domain
operations
in the past our battles were fought and
won in a single domain
such as the battle of the monitor in the
merrimack the battle of britain
the battle of the bulge operation
linebacker
just to name a few those days are gone
the future of warfare is conflicts that
simultaneously
engage maritime land air
cyber space and space domains all of
which are enabled by data
multi-domain operations is nothing more
than the recognition that in order to
compete successfully
the us military will need to leverage
more than one domain
and likely all five domains
simultaneously
because of this need connectivity
between the five domains of war is
paramount
and must be enabled by a system of
systems that facilitates fast
accurate and reliable data flow between
every node in the system
joint all domain command and control
what we call
jad c2 is the multi-domain enabled
iteration of command and control that
provides unity of command
and flexibility and scalability for the
theater commanders across
all domains and it is the system of
systems being developed by the air force
to enable warfighting capabilities and
replace the aging command and control
platforms
currently in use the large graphic on
the slide
indicates some of the core components of
this internet military
things each of which is identified by
its function
and the suffix o-n-e or one
to indicate its universality as a source
note of that function
so for example the centralized data
repository in abms or air
battle management system is data one the
open
architecture moving target indicator is
open mti one
and the unified cloud solution is cloud
one and so on and so forth
why does all of this matter as the
graphic indicates the central node of
abms
is its integrated data cloud based
architecture
data drives the entire concept of
operations
general charles brown the chief of staff
of the air force hit the nail on the
head
when he spoke at the national defense
industrial association earlier this year
and highlighted data as the most
critical component
of abms and jazz c2 he said
we have a lot of data we just don't
publish it
we don't share it like we should we must
accelerate the change required to
connect
all our platforms and sensors and our
weapon systems
we must develop the infrastructure for
the digital backbone
for the data so where does this leave
acc
as the air force's largest match com and
its lead match count for air dominance
in cyber operations
acc plays a leading role in enabling the
air force's success through abms
but what we have is a ways to go until
we realize that vision
our goals and observations include the
findings
on the left of the saw of the slide we
need to be better at viewing data as a
warfighting asset
this is a cultural issue as much as a
technological issue
and we need to help our entire workforce
understand
that data is a commodity that enables
success in
every other area of our operations
enterprise data management is critical
to enabling our
future readiness agility and
effectiveness
without good enterprise data management
in place
our vast shows of data become a
hindrance rather than enabler
to our combat operations data
architecture improvements are
desperately required
to optimize our infrastructure
consumption maximize
data sharing and unlock our analytics
and exploitation capabilities
acc needs a robust data classification
and access capability that's compatible
with intelligence community
and our joint and international partners
and that classifies data at the
attribute level
this will avoid stovepipes and silos
created when data is classified at the
system
network or data set level and last
acc will benefit from processes
automation capabilities
and analytics sandboxes these
capabilities will lead to greater
precision
better tracking higher output and
increase acc's ability
to scale to meet operational needs so
how do we get there
our new data architecture will be key to
enabling the points
discussed on the previous page this is a
top-level view of the reference
architecture with the flow of data
into the architecture depicted from left
to right
the flow begins with data sources on the
far left-hand side
these various mission systems across
operational spectrum from readiness
monitoring
services and financial management
platforms to sensitive isr
and air superiority fighters that
generate data of all types
in the acquisition phase those data
sources are ingested into the
architecture
this could be via an application program
interface
automated etl streaming or other method
that
that point is that architecture is open
flexible able to adapt to the diverse
technical capabilities
of all of our mission systems in the
data martialing
the data process vetted integrated
arrayed
processed and stored this stage of the
architecture is format agnostic
and should include a variety of
databases for all data
types at this point the data should be
visible
accessible understood linked and trusted
vault if you remember before the
accessibility of the data will be
evident in data
access through which end users and
analysis
analysts are able to access the data
through application program interfaces
native extract transform and load
processes
custom streams and more and in enhancing
understanding in the enterprise
reporting and analytics stage
those same users will be able to
leverage a robust setup
information consumption capabilities
that enable data science
data discovery data dashboards
geospatial analysis
and more action takes place once the
data reaches
target applications this is the when the
data completes its journey through the
architecture
arriving at the target to enable
terminal weapon systems
to do its job undergirding all of these
infrastructure services and enterprise
information management services
we have metadata management master data
management
information life cycle management and
others that we spoke about on slide
three this slide shows three of our use
cases that we have developed to
demonstrate the full scale of our data
improvements
if you direct your attention to the
legend at the bottom right you'll see
that this graphic highlights various
theater equities and the roles they play
in a specific use case
the green dots show involvement in our
dynamic targeting use case
the white dots show involvement in our
joint cyber defense use case
and the blue dots show involvement in
our readiness use case
the first use case supports acc as the
lead command for jad c2 dynamic
targeting
with enterprise data solutions that
integrate and present data to the
warfighter
at the speed of war the acc mission
requires advanced data sharing
as the bedrock of next generation
information superiority
key programs of records such as air
operation centers or
aocs and distributed common ground
systems or dcgs
offer warfighters silo-like capabilities
in their proposed current framework
but if properly integrated into a
unified enterprise
architecture would become force
multipliers within abms
aocs will leverage the abms c2 or
command and control framework
jag c2 dynamic targeting and dcgs's
time dominant fusion capabilities to
execute their find
and fix capability in near real time
ultimately data improves will
demonstrate
information superiority with integrated
data driven
operations to an entire kill chain which
starts with
the theater taskings from the joint
force air combat
commander to the dcgs target and intel
reporting
then through the automation of near
real-time threat reporting
to the aoc which concludes with the
transmission of the task
and the target to the weapon system the
second use case
will integrate the u.s space force's
defensive cyber operations mission data
with add cyber into cyber commands big
data platforms
and additional data sharing technologies
like
us cybercom unified platform the space
forces unified data library
and the air force's vault to demonstrate
the cyberspace domain awareness
the desired end state is that both acc
and u.s space force can leverage data
from joint full spectrum ops
into integrated platform to expedite
counter adversary tactics techniques
and procedures and big data platforms
like elixir
will be integrated into the acc data
architecture
the third use case will provide a tool
set and methodology for air combat
command to comprehensively evaluate
the aggregated operational readiness of
its warfighting forces
at all echelons and across multiple
measures of effectiveness
in sum the current process in which we
measure readiness
is in a binary go no go mentality
and uses legacy readiness metrics for
analysis with very little
mere real-time insight into actual
readiness down to the squadron echelon
in order to holistically understand
readiness our data must be integrated to
conduct data discovery
and arrange systematically for advanced
analytics
the end state of this use case is
improved squadron unit readiness
with acc unit commanders able to
identify
analyze understand and forecast in near
real time
unit readiness and effectiveness for
current and future operations
to move forward towards this realized
state we've developed a plan
pursuant to the directors of the
department of defense and air force
headquarters
we've created an operational plan to
implement key improvements across our
architecture
governance standards and talents and
culture
the blue lines of effort or loes on this
slide
are from the air force data strategy
implementation plan
and our team has identified key tasks
and actions for acc within those loes
1 sets the foundation by focusing on
building our acc data management office
headed by the acc deputy command data
officer
we also intend to hire a command data
architect and associated support staff
to grow and expand this effort over the
next 12 months
loe 2 directs how we are evolving the
workforce
by identifying data stewards who are
responsible for managing
data assets across acc as well as
working on establishing
training and continuing education plans
for these stewards
another item we're exploring within this
loa is setting up a center of excellence
to a data specialist to the data fluent
this center of excellence would also
have a significant charter to grow
and develop acc's use of advanced
analytics
especially artificial intelligence and
machine learning
loe 3 presents positions and protects
data in this loe we will build out
architecture
and process standards improvements like
metadata management
with a focus on driving interoperability
by conforming to federal
dod and air force standards and creating
standards that don't exist today
in lov4 we'll focus on building
optimizing and opera operationalizing
our architectural improvements
by delivering them to the warfighter and
incorporating them into broader
frameworks like abms a natural extension
of le1
is loe 5 management and governance
in this loe we will empower the data
management office
and every data management professional
across acc
to own and establish a partnership
between mission
operations and i t to deliver a
proactive data governance capability
this means developing a common
governance framework for the data
management office to provide
toolkits and resources to stewards and
always driving integration between our
data management office
and headquarters air force in loe number
six
converging means integrating resource
and budgeting approaches
between other match cons and the
department of air force
while aligning our data management
efforts across the dod
and with partner nations we have a long
way to go
but we're excited about the journey
ahead so with that
i would like to thank you all for
allowing me the opportunity to deliver
these presentations
these are exciting times for acc and the
air force
and as general brown the chief of staff
of the air force says we must accelerate
change or lose everyone have a great air
force day
thank you thank you very much for that
wonderful talk
uh it's nice to have our second second
military member for this conference
uh thank you very much colonel alfredo
so with that we have